write down the number you see in your
display write it down on your page e
equals now this a here it's called a for
a couple of reasons what kind of
function were we just investigating just
now exponential functions thank you very
much
if you want to make a title you can call
this calculus of exponential functions
now we looked at a bunch of different
exponential functions a bunch of
different ones like 2 to power X 3 to
power X 4 to the power of X and so on
but when you make the base this number
right when you made the base this number
something unusual happened namely when
we tried to take this not to the power
of X naught 3 to the power of X where
you took e to the power of X when we had
a look at that derivative that blue
graph what was it it was exactly the
same as the graph we started with in
other words you take this e to the X
business when you differentiate it what
you get back is a to the power of X it's
a weird function because unlike all
these other ones we've seen when you
differentiate some radical
transformation happens when you
differentiate this guy right you get
back exactly the same function now it's
very important that I point out you can
see my dots going here right on your
calculator display if your calculator is
the same as mine it stops at a really
convenient slash inconvenient place
because you'll notice does yours say the
same thing is mine yep one eight two
eight one eight two eight and it seems
like oh I wonder if that continues that
pattern one eight to eight and so on
right it doesn't if you go back to your
computer which is probably still open in
desmos what I'd like you to do is I type
in type in the letter E and it'll give
you a few more decimal places not a
whole lot more if you want more you can
go into Google and ask it what E is
equal to but you notice you've got one
eight two eight one eight two eight and
then the pattern just kind of explodes
right this number E just
it'll give it to you right this number E
is a bit like the number pi right PI's
decimal places they keep on going and
changing forever and ever and ever it is
actually a special category of number
called a transcendental number which
makes it really super special okay all
right so you've got that there on your
screen now this guy here is going to be
really important for us to use right we
can actually understand a whole family
of functions like this on top of all of
the different X and differential
differentiation stuff that we already
know so if you haven't already go ahead
open up your textbook and we're gonna
see how we can use this so what we'll
have you look at here this is the very
very first question in to see so if you
haven't got it there open and you can
just have a look with me and the
question does not say exactly this but
I'm gonna write it like this just to
make it easier for us to deal with as
you'll see in a second okay no this is
not the function we just looked at right
it's very closely related it's got that
a that 2.71 business number down there
but then you've got this two up in the
top okay now what we want to do here is
recognize that this is not just a
function this is a function of a
function
do you remember we learned a rule to
deal with differentiating functions when
these functions tucked inside other
functions then I wonder what is called
yeah you can write it as f of G of X I
know these are the product rule we're
gonna look at the product of shortly but
I don't see any property this is the
chain rule okay can you raise your hand
and if you don't want to it's fine
but who remembers the chain rule and how
to use it no that's the product rule
Saburo anyone yes no okay all right
let's let's review it and this is
exactly why I've written it this way
okay over on the right hand side here of
your work in if you have another color
this might be helpful what I want us to
write is let and I'm going to introduce
a substitution I'm gonna say let u equal
to X so what I'm doing here is I'm
trying to turn this function here into
something that looks a bit simpler okay
so if u equals 2x then I can rewrite
this original function as Y
equals e to the power of what what am i
swapping in just you that's all
I've just done that for that okay so far
so good now why have I done this it's so
that if I have a look at this function
here and this function here I can
differentiate both of them individually
and then I can put the derivatives
together this is how the chain rule
worked and that's why I'm trying to
remind you okay so let's have a got this
one first you equals 2x if I
differentiate this guy this is just 2
very good so I've got that fantastic
come down to this guy I can
differentiate this as well it's not
going to be dy r DX anymore why not that
one look closely yeah I've got no X's
here yeah no X's so I'm not going to
differentiate with respect to X I'm
gonna differentiate with respect to u dy
on do you now just look closely compare
whoops this line to this one right this
is just that special magic number two
point seven one etc to the power of our
variable here so when you differentiate
it what did we say when you
differentiate e to the power of that
what changes is it is there a change
there's no change at all right so if you
differentiate a of you what do you
expect to get back to the power of you
like so okay so I've got one derivative
here one derivative here and I can put
them together to get the actual
derivative that I wanted so this to
refresh your memory this is the way we
stated the chain rule it's one
derivative chain together with the other
one you can see essentially here I'm
treating these almost like they're
regular fractions they're not exactly
there's all limits and stuff hiding
behind there but for this case I can
actually treat this to you and this to
you like a common thing on the numerator
and the denominator does that make sense
what happens when you've got a common
thing on the numerator and denominator
just cancel them right
Bam Bam they're all going to go but I
I'm gonna say it's either power of U
that's what I worked out just one line
before and what's this guy I worked it
out over here it's just two
okay let's tie this all up in a nicely
both right my original question never
had use in and I introduced that to help
me solve the question so since that was
something I put in I'd better take it
back out right so I'm gonna say the
actual derivative instead of writing it
is a ^ u what do I swap you out for d ^
2 x very good x - usually we write these
constant coefficients just out the front
like so there's my derivative ok now
this took a little bit of a while
because I want us to remember this chain
rule but hopefully now if you just
looked back at this original line here
right I want us to get to the point
where we feel comfortable enough to
actually more or less go straight here
right that - that came out when it comes
from in this line where did it come from
it came from up in a power right so
essentially what I was doing was
treating this guy as a function to
differentiate your differentiate and you
get this - right and then I treat the
outside thing as its own function to
differentiate its e to the power of the
thing what happens when you
differentiate e to the power of
something you just it just stays the
same yeah fantastic